but let's go man he don't give a [__]
about nothing dude I got the coolest
girl on her yo you give her so much love
man it's great seeing all these like
there's so many like podcasts that
you've been doing recently they've been
going these little moments going viral
obviously the Rogan Experience was great
for you oh man but you know getting back
into that that relationship I don't know
it's something I can also relate to it's
like getting somebody that is your
partner and someone that you want to
build something with
I don't think it's a coincidence that
my career is taken off I mean obviously
there's a lot of other parts and these
people deserve credit too all you guys
but like having that person that's 30
for you allows you to really focus oh
for sure and also just quitting chasing
tail like just when you focus on one
chick like my phone freed up so much
space yeah you know what I mean like all
these little unnecessary just trying to
drag along shits you know what I mean
it's like and man to have somebody that
just really stands behind you yeah like
bunny is all about she gets it like I
sit down with her 18 months ago and I'm
like look
there's a chance that if we do this
right
three years from now we can look back
and we can pave our own future forever
but you just got to be patient with me
and know that I'm going to be in the
wind and like no hesitation she was like
you could I could have told her I was
going to [__] Iraq and she'd have
been like [__] see you when you get
back I trust it like trust like she just
like that kind of support that
unwavering moment where you're like look
you don't get to do this you only get to
do this the first time one time yeah
that's it if we come back around God
willing I hope I come back around but
I'll be old news you know I'll talk
we'll talk about current events next
time I'm on this podcast jelly roll
story right did you did you uh did you
drop like a pickup line on her when you
first met her no dude you said no I was
an [__] man I just I looked at her
and immediately assessed that it was
[__] a problem
just like she had a dude at the time and
he was like super aggressive and just
like it was a lot there's a lot of
energy coming from that whole scenario
this is you met there we met at a bar
dude like [__] 1972 it was awesome
I'm doing a soft ticket show on Fremont
Street nobody's there to see me I'm on
stage with people people got their back
turned to me having conversations it's
one of those shows Fremont is down old
Vegas
old Vegas and I just immediately was
attracted to her and was he coming to
see you or was she just going they were
just at the bar yeah yeah it was a total
it was just like Vegas maybe her dude at
the time knew a dude that worked for me
or something but it wasn't like we're
coming to see jelly roll thing I was
like yo the homies in town at a bar yeah
kind of thing you know and um that dude
ended up going to jail and when he did
she kind of reached out yeah and I
thought she was just being cool like
just in general and I was like there's
no way she's you know and then one night
she shot her shot what'd she say yo she
well she came into the room we were all
in and just sat on my lap and like we've
been friends for like a year and I was
like yo and you know Bunny's got that
goddamn thing on her side
Bunny's got that thing on her so bunny
sits down and I'm like oh no this ain't
straight you know what I'm saying did
you get bricked well she wouldn't have
felt it anyways
[Laughter]
but she sit down I was just like okay
and there's no way this is happening I
was like this might be something and
then we ended up at the little bar that
night and and had a couple couple drinks
and she she kissed me and we went back
to the house and man she tried to [__]
me and I was like hold on hold on hold
on hold on I need to know what you're
trying to do with your life before I let
you put that [__] on me and [__] my
life up
telling her yes and she picks on me
about it to this day obviously she said
I asked her for her Five-Year Plan I may
have I was just like I was intimidated
too dude this girl like the balls on you
living in the 90s what do you want to do
with yourself
where'd you graduate were you at her
house yeah well I was sleeping on the
couch and then I graduated to the
bedroom in her house yeah in her house
so the first time she said I'm extremely
homeless by the way yeah if I couldn't
sleep on her couch I'd have slept in my
van outside of her house
this time right she had real money too
she I was intimidated too I think maybe
there was a side of me that's
embarrassing to admit that she's gonna
see anything on me forever if maybe a
side of me just stalled because she just
walked in and I was like this is wild
you know what I mean I mean like she's
in shoes or something no she was
completely naked
put your [__]
why'd he just did that tell me what's
wrong
I will not let you take away from
because I will not be projected as the
average fat person that was bro for sure
you know my wife will tell you that come
on my wife I believe this I was not
hurting in the you know I've done
relatively well for myself for what I
have to offer for sure I've done
extremely well in every Department kind
of I mean you know [__] I've done a lot
with a lot maybe
I've done a lot with a lot holding me
back there you go you know but yeah she
just it was something about her too that
was like man I didn't I knew immediately
as corny as it sounds that it I didn't
want to play that game hold on so she
comes in butt naked yeah yeah yeah and
kind of crawls up on me and whoa and I'm
like oh hold on now regroup time out
time out yeah I'm saying I'm like let's
chat about this I didn't see this
escalating so quickly
we kind of
give me a second here figure this out
okay what are we doing right now she's
probably never been rejected by a man
ever in her life yeah for sure so what
is going through her head in this moment
what the [__] is wrong with you if she
says that just like that and I'm like
what the [__] is wrong I'm just like yo
like are we just like [__] or what
are we doing she was like I really like
you I was like then cool what are we
doing like what are you doing you know
what I mean like what's our plan here
because you know don't don't I could
tell this was entrapment you know what
I'm saying I was like this is something
different happened or something no I
just thought like I just thought like yo
don't don't have to be out here looking
silly you know what I mean because I've
been we've been friends we were homies
it was like you think she was gonna try
to steal your van yeah
[Laughter]
I'm just instantly getting snobby like
hold on you [__] drink whole milk
[Laughter]
okay so you don't have sex that night
yeah no we do oh you do yeah about seven
in the morning you know so we went we
talked for a while though it was kind of
turned out being she don't want to admit
this part but it turned out kind of
romantic like in a really cool like we
leveled with each other in a real way
and it was just like yo I was like I'm
cold with us just whatever but like it's
just not wake up tomorrow and have to
deal with this like what's what's up
like we've been friends a long time at
this point she's already helped me pick
out
a bed for my daughter and I'm trying to
get custody of the kids she knows all
these other factors are like she knows
she's still in and I'm like where are we
you know like you know where I'm at if
like if this ain't a serious thing
that's cool too and just where is this
happening you know what I mean that
feelings already I knew that I loved
that girl I knew I loved her the night I
met her at the bar be real were you
stalling for the whiskey dick to wear
for sure
[Laughter]
still going strong but first we do have
tickets left for one special taping in
Houston at White Oak Music Hall
September 1st hurry up and buy those
tickets before they sell out but bum ass
cities back to you Indianapolis I think
is called naptown I don't really know to
be honest with you I'm just trying to
act like I know things August 23rd I'm
gonna be there Louisville Kentucky
probably the only Indian there August
24th and then Poughkeepsie
p-o-u-g-h-k-e-p-s-i-e I'm gonna be there
August 25th and 26th those dates and
more also Stress Factory India when I
say that in I mean New Jersey I need to
see y'all the stress Factory I'm gonna
be there September 15th and 16th get
your tickets at Akash Singh com now
let's get back to the show or maybe
Mark's got some announcements sorry
just got off a call with Hollywood turns
out we have a show in Virginia Beach
that's right this Thursday August 17th
Virginia Beach Virginia Schultz's show
is sold out you know her show isn't sold
out me and Derek post and that's where
we're going to be Virginia Beach August
17th and then in September September 7th
we're at Vulcan gas company in Austin
Texas Schultz we're going down there
we're doing them
guys you know what you can do
suck his penis after the show please
don't when we were an option when we're
in parade a lot of people try to suck my
penis I didn't like that one bit all
right I didn't enjoy it but if you want
to come out maybe shake my hand or just
say hello Virginia Beach this Thursday
August 17th and then Vulcan gas company
September 7th Austin Texas I cannot wait
to see you guys we're gonna say hi to
everyone afterwards we're gonna do a
meet and greet I'm giving everyone a big
hug we're taking pictures with every
single person that comes out
okay this is inappropriate we can edit
that product I'll see you don't have to
though this is my mom watches us let's
get back to the show the single best
decision I've made in my whole life
second they're probably getting custody
of Bailey is Mary and Bunny and I always
say Marion bunny was probably the
biggest decision I ever made because I
don't think I got custody of my daughter
without her wow initially
by her she's successful you know I mean
also like the line of work she's in
initially is like were you were you
scared by that were you scared that you
were going to get like jealous were you
scared that you were gonna get your
heart broken like no whenever I was
young
so when I made I came out on bond at 17
where I got charged an adult for one for
the second robbery case yeah and I
immediately found a home in the local
strip club and
I had a couple ladies in there that I
fancied and they fancied me and and we
had a so I kind of at early age
kind of wasn't just didn't care like I
understood the concept of these girls
dance all night and then we go to
[__] each Steak and Shake and go home
you know what I mean so like I always
kind of separated that you were dating
two girls at the same time from the
shame strip club yeah it was a unique
thing
that was their names this [__]
yeah this is this is this is a true
thing bro yeah for sure
[Music]
was her name that was their stage names
out there but they know who they are
so both of them were they friends with
each other yeah they were ish they kind
of played they played well together it
wasn't like a like a you know I was
messing with one girl and she knew I
kind of messed with the other girl and
the other girl worked multiple strip
clubs but it was a but everybody was
cool with it yeah the parallel was kind
of the other would you all kind of hook
up together no no I never got that
luxury at that moment whose luxury is
the third stripper too
no bunny brought the luxury dude bunny
brought the first two years me and Bunny
were together man she brought so many
women home wait wait it was Unreal could
you imagine
there is a skin a skinny dude watching
this right now with a six-pack that's
worked out every day of his life he is
taking dating classes he's watched uh
Hancock or which one was the Will Smith
movie about the Danny thing
[Laughter]
does she tell you she's bringing girls
home the first thing she was like I knew
that was something she was with for sure
and then I didn't know how fast she
would act on it first time what happened
oh Jesus you got a phone call or just
she brings me no we're just we're just
out with one of her friends and she just
tells her friend she's like you should
just come home with us it was crazy it
was wild and I was like at that moment I
was like this could be my new normal and
that would that we did that for years
did you get up immediately or did you
have to start a [__] seven
no I didn't care about the other girl's
Five-Year Plan yeah
[Laughter]
short-term thing
teach you how to have a threesome
yeah sort of bunny had to teach me a lot
of stuff because I thought I was like
I'm still not
I'm still green as a pool table twice a
square when it comes to sex in
comparison to her right you know what I
mean because the business she comes from
and that's something else that's still
intimidates me about bunny dude it's
like bunny is like
you know like you could like you ever
heard of a such and such and I'll be
like never and she was like it's a dude
I'm like it's the nastiest thing I've
ever heard in my life you know what I'm
saying and I'm like nothing I can't
believe that arouses men you know what
I'm saying like she comes from that
place you know her story is the best
story on Earth she says the day that she
got realized that it was different was
that she was working at a strip club and
I hope I tell the story right Mama Bear
she said that the girl came and the dude
came and said I'll give you a thousand
dollars to kick me in the nuts right now
wow and she was like absolutely not so
she goes and tells her homegirl it's
[__] pervert back here offered me a
thousand dollars kick him the nuts her
homegirl girls follow me walks over
there and goes is this him he says yes
she walks up she goes give me the money
the dude has the money the girl just
kicks him right in the nuts right and
then she looks at Bunny and goes you
better take out money next time girl and
but it was like right then you know what
I mean she's like [__] from I had
some strip club stories but not that you
know what I'm saying for sure holy [__]
we need to get money on Flavor bunnies
wildest stories on Earth it is and you
guys will talk about them you feel
comfortable as you're never like jealous
or she's telling old stories from the
strip clubs yeah no I'm not a jealousy
is not a trait of mine how do you
compartmentalize that because that's the
woman you love yeah you know and then
she's talking about other guys well let
me give you this perspective man was
we're all homies here right yeah and
we've y'all I watched y'all laugh and
talk about Laney right like what dudes
do like as a natural thing is like we do
dude stuff
then we'll call our wife our best friend
we'll say none of that to her that's
true you know what I'm saying so it's
like I'll say it to her yeah you got a
[__] wagon yeah for sure but it's
like where bunnies like that was part of
us being best friends was
I think that's the Charming part of our
relationship is that I can be like yo
such and such is [__] fire like yo I
like I'll send Bunny Instagrams like yo
you seen this girl you know what I mean
like bunnies like it's never like an
awkward thing with bunny about stuff
like that and I don't so in return and
the problem is most dudes that have that
relationship with their girl it's not
the other way like but God forbid their
girl likes a dude's picture with his
shirt off or something and this same
dude that's
[Music]
none of that stuff but man that's my
best friend dude so if she if bunny
really wanted to go [__] a dude it would
be just like me and you being friends
and me being like yo man I kind of want
to go [__] this girl yeah bunny would
sit me down look me in the eye and go yo
I like really I'm attracted to this for
whatever reason like that's a big part
of like
we're best like we're really we carry
each other like this
what I mean and
can I ask you if she's ever said that
has she ever been like I'm into she's
never actually we had one time where me
and her were in a rough patch and she
was just like yo if we don't figure this
out human Nature's going to take over
you know what I mean wow
you know what I mean and I respected
that you know that that was cool and
that's just a part of our our Dynamic I
think it's what makes it you know
communication man just talking being
honest this way we don't ever have to
feel awkward you never feel like I never
had to feel like I get caught on
Instagram if she's looking over my
shoulder so there's no pretending with
you guys because she's seen you at your
absolute lowest and I might have seen
her with money but I've seen her at her
lowest too because that's something else
you know what I mean when like bunny
don't do no drugs now bunny don't drink
I don't do cocaine no more like we're
relatively you know I noticed your list
is a lot less restrictive than hers
we met each other in that dark place and
we we would sit out and talk about that
Five-Year Plan dog we I'll get him I
don't want to get the most from talking
about but like get emotional we would
like dream of this [__] bro like we
would be like
she's like I'm gonna start a podcast and
I'm gonna do this and this is how I'm
gonna get out of this and I'm gonna do
this and like I'm gonna do this and I'll
be like cool and I'm gonna do this and
I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna do this
and then we like
[__] figure that [__] out together
you know what I'm saying like it's
[__] kind of the greatest American
story ever told that's how I feel about
it you know what I mean one of the best
things to do
I think with your partner is plan oh a
future Dreamcast
do what do you want to make where do you
want to go I don't care if it's a
vacation I don't care if it's a house
what would you want your house to look
like and just set that vision and I
think it's really one that's really
comforting to know that that other
person is like hey we're working towards
this but two it's like yeah my life is
with you in this when I think about the
future yeah it's with both of us for
sure yeah yeah it's awesome I don't
think you should ever stop doing it no I
don't if you're 70 years old hey where
do you want to go on vacation next
summer where do you want to go on
vacation when we're 80. where do you
want to retire that's it as long as
you're planning ahead that's it dude and
that's what we're doing that's the [__]
we're talking about it's like and that's
the [__] we talked about from day one
she jokes that first night that I asked
for a Five-Year Plan yeah that next
morning we really did make a five-year
plan and knock that [__] out the
park wow you know what I mean like that
we sat down
every year now we have a joke that every
year we look at each other and go we
still into this and this year was the
first year that she looked at me I was
like we still into this and I was like
bunny I'm gonna tell you the truth I'm
making forever plans for us now like I'm
not even in five years no more like the
decisions I'm making for our family
right now where I'm putting my money and
the Investments I'm making on behalf of
our family even outside of the
Investments you're making I'm planning
on us doing this forever wow I'm
thinking about Bailey's kids you know
what I mean like that's where my
thoughts are like I don't I couldn't
imagine being with nobody else but my
wife yeah you know and you could if you
wanted to yeah for sure yeah I mean
from you a little bit to like they throw
a bunch of [__] in the beginning and
then you go I don't really need all that
yeah and now you're [__] faithful for
the rest of your life yeah it's kind of
a genius plan really brilliant for both
parties no for sure you know what
they're doing these women man yeah
yeah
they're definitely smarter than us bunny
still carries I'd say our whole you know
I mean even down to like
the whole house dude like I don't know
what's happening with that house yeah
same how great is that yeah it's [__]
the best feeling on Earth I'm so
disconnected from it like I know in 30
years me and you will both be living in
a van while our wives
now it's just awesome
these idiots don't even have it in their
name
[Laughter]
when I was seven or something I have a
restaurant that failed in my name yeah
we out here yo we out here bro what's up
this is awesome rebuilt that credit
score you got it I'll never forget the
first time I looked into my credit score
and they were like I guess you owe Bill
South which was eight I guess 18. that's
how long ago was Bell South they said
which ended up getting picked up by
collection agency for like 18 Grand I
was like what year was this it was like
97 I was like I was 12. you know what
I'm saying I was like what the [__] is
happening here
stuff down to my credit
oh that's crazy yeah white trash red
it's fine